Liebe Freunde der Sonne.
Und liebe Feinde der Sonne.
Also ... Freunde des Mondes?
Wir haben in den letzten Wochen
hier im Team sehr viel diskutiert
und uns die Köpfe
darüber zerbrochen,
was wir jetzt eigentlich ...
damit machen.
Mit den Kommentaren.
Bisher hatten wir
in den Kommentaren
so gut wie gar nichts
gelöscht oder geblockt,
damit sind wir
eigentlich ganz gut gefahren.
Aber in letzter Zeit
schreiben uns immer mehr Leute,
doch bitte
etwas mehr durchzugreifen,
weil die Kommentarspalte
teilweise so ne Shitshow ist,
dass es
gar nicht mehr möglich ist,
ein respektvolle
inhaltliche Diskussion zu führen.
Deswegen werden wir ab jetzt alle
Kommentare automatisch zurückhalten
und sie manuell freigeben,
und zwar nur,
wenn sie folgende Kriterien erfüllen:
Also, ernsthaft jetzt,
wir sind tatsächlich dabei,
uns gerade ein paar
Community-Regeln aufzustellen.
Darüber wollten wir euch
zum einen hier transparent aufklären,
zum anderen glaube ich,
dass dieses Thema,
"Wie wollen wir
im Netz diskutieren?",
"Wie können wir
respektvoll diskutieren?",
echt grade große Relevanz hat
und so ne Herausforderung
unserer Zeit ist.
Ich mein, ja, viele der übertriebenen
Emotionen und Aggressionen
würden von Angesicht zu Angesicht
so wahrscheinlich nie stattfinden,
Symbolbild hier.
Aber natürlich kann man auch nicht
einfach mit der Schulter zucken,
wenn zum Beispiel Karl Lauterbach
stapelweise Mord- und Gewaltdrohungen
anzeigen muss.
Diese vergiftete Diskussionskultur -
also, mit Kultur hat das ja
leider gar nix mehr zu tun -
betrifft ja letztendlich alle,
die sich im Netz
an Diskussionen beteiligen,
sei es jetzt auf YouTube
oder auf Facebook oder Twitter.
Deswegen hoffe ich, dass dieses Video
vielleicht auch euch helfen kann,
indem ihr das eine oder andere auch
für euch übernehmt, wenn ihr wollt.
Also, holt euch 'n Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich,
wir steigen durch.
Also, wir werden hier bei maiLab
nach wie vor mit Löschen und Blocken
versuchen,
recht sparsam umzugehen.
Möglicherweise sparsamer,
als sich manche wünschen würden.
Warum wir da
recht viel tolerieren möchten
und warum wir etwas viel Besseres
haben als Löschen und Blocken,
das erklär ich gleich im Detail.
Aber eine grundsätzliche Sache
vorweg:
Das ist unsere Entscheidung
für diesen Kanal.
Wie andere das handhaben,
ob sie jetzt mehr löschen und blocken
oder Kommentare ganz ausschalten,
wie auch immer,
das ist ihr gutes Recht.
Hausrecht sozusagen, denn:
Ja, es ist mein Grundrecht,
meine Meinung frei zu äußern.
Aber es ist nicht mein Grundrecht,
bei ner Talkshow
ununterbrochen zu reden
und niemand anderen
zu Wort kommen zu lassen.
Es ist nicht mein Grundrecht,
in ne Bibliothek zu gehen,
herumzuschreien
und nicht rausgeschmissen zu werden.
Oder nicht geblockt zu werden.
Nur weil ich ein Grundrecht
auf freie Meinungsäußerung habe,
hab ich kein Grundrecht darauf,
dass sich jeder
meine Meinung anhören muss.
That being said:
Hier bei maiLab finden wir's gut,
wenn möglichst viele unterschiedliche
Meinungen und Ansichten
in den Kommentaren
zu Wort kommen,
auch wenn das zwangsläufig heißt,
dass dann manches dabei ist,
das nicht so nett ist.
Nicht zuletzt,
weil wir ein Wissenschaftskanal sind
und hier wissenschaftliches Denken
und wissenschaftliche
Diskussionskultur feiern wollen.
Und das verlangt einfach
eine ganz besondere Offenheit
gegenüber anderen Meinungen
und auch gegenüber Kritik.
Aber:
Wissenschaftliche Diskussionskultur
lebt von Offenheit und Toleranz.
Intolerant sind Menschen,
die rationalen Diskurs verweigern
oder gegen Andersdenkende
zur Gewalt aufrufen
beziehungsweise
sogar selbst Gewalt anwenden.
So definierte es zumindest der
Wissenschaftsphilosoph Karl Popper.
Von ihm stammt auch das ...
Rassismus zum Beispiel darf in einer
freien, toleranten Gesellschaft
nicht toleriert werden,
wenn man Freiheit und Toleranz
schützen möchte.
Alles zu tolerieren
führt zu Intoleranz.
Für unsere Kommentare heißt das:
Um einen sachlichen, freien
offenen Diskurs zu ermöglichen,
sollte man manche Sachen
dann eben auch nicht tolerieren.
Wir haben bei maiLab
ziemlich begrenzte Kapazitäten
für unser Community-Management,
also für alles,
was mit den Kommentaren zu tun hat.
Anfangs konnte ich das
noch alleine machen,
inzwischen findet ihr unter dem
maiLab-Account uns als Team.
Am meisten ist momentan Lars aktiv,
den alten Freunden der Sonne
noch bekannt als "Lars und die Welt".
Wir finden, dass man hier,
bei diesem Kanal,
nur dann sinnvoll
Community-Management machen kann,
wenn man sich auch gut genug
mit den wissenschaftlichen Inhalten
im Detail auskennt.
Unser Community-Management
muss also jemand aus unserer
wissenschaftlichen Redaktion machen.
Aber natürlich stecken wir
unsere wissenschaftliche Expertise
und unsere begrenzten,
endlichen Kapazitäten
in erster Linie
in die Videos,
und nur sekundär
ins Community-Management.
Wir glauben aber immer noch daran,
dass jenseits von ...
.. immer noch der Großteil
dieser Community Bock hat
auf inhaltliche,
sachliche Diskussion.
Und auf einen respektvollen,
humorvollen Umgang miteinander.
Und wir setzen da auch auf euch
als Community.
Denn ich glaube,
jeder Einzelne von euch
kann uns ernsthaft helfen. Passt auf.
Es gibt letztendlich
grob drei Arten,
wie man mit unschönen Kommentaren
umgehen kann.
Also, ihr könnt melden,
wir können löschen und blocken.
Es gibt erst mal
ganz klare No-Gos,
die gegen die Menschlichkeit
und sowieso auch gegen die
YouTube-Richtlinien verstoßen.
Gewalt- oder Mordandrohungen,
menschenverachtende Kommentare,
Rassismus,
sexuelle Belästigungen,
verfassungswidrige Aussagen
wie Holocaustleugnung usw.
Wenn wir so was sehen
wird's ohne Umschweife gelöscht,
geblockt und gegebenenfalls
zur Anzeige gebracht.
Und hier muss ich einräumen, hier
waren wir bisher etwas nachlässig,
weil es zeitweise
unsere Kapazitäten überstiegen hatte.
Doch wir sind bereits dabei,
das zu ändern,
weil's auch eben
wirklich wichtig ist.
Außerdem blocken wir Spam,
so was hier zum Beispiel.
Und auch ihr könnt natürlich
Spam melden, wenn ihr's seht.
Grundsätzlich werden wir alles,
was offensichtlich mit Copy-Paste
einfach mehrfach
in die Kommentare geballert wird,
als Spam einstufen und loswerden.
Und da ist uns inzwischen
auch ganz egal,
was für eine Art von Inhalt das ist,
auch wenn es etwas Positives ist.
Das können wir nicht unterstützen,
denn wenn jeder seine Kommentare
20-mal immer hier hin kopieren würde,
wo kämen wir da hin?
Schneller in die Trends
wahrscheinlich.
Aber darum geht es nicht, lasst es.
Wir löschen das.
So weit, so einfach.
Komplizierter wird es
zum Beispiel mit Beleidigungen,
die verletzen, die Diskussion
unnötig verunsachlichen,
die aber nicht
zu den klaren No-Gos gehören,
die wir grade genannt haben.
Wenn's nach mir ginge
und nach uns ginge,
nach unserem Team ginge, würden wir
alle auf Beleidigungen verzichten.
Aber nur weil wir
etwas nicht gut finden,
wollen wir's nicht direkt löschen
oder blocken.
Das fängt ja schon damit an:
Was ist ne Beleidigung überhaupt?
Manchmal ist es ziemlich einfach.
Aber man kann auch
ohne grobe Schimpfwörter
richtig verletzend sein.
Und was man als Beleidigung empfindet
ist sehr subjektiv.
Also, ich finde diese Pfeifhasen
jetzt nicht soo süß.
Wie ...
Wie kannst ... Boah.
Wir haben aber beschlossen,
dass wir Beleidigungen,
jenseits der klaren No-Gos,
dann löschen beziehungsweise
die User dann auch komplett blocken,
wenn wir sehen, dass jemand wirklich
in erster Linie beleidigen möchte
und offenbar
kein Interesse daran hat,
eine echte Diskussion zu führen.
Und das ist dann einfach
unsere redaktionelle Entscheidung
von Fall zu Fall.
Und ich hoffe,
das macht Sinn für euch,
dass das in unserem Ermessen liegt
und dass wir da keine klaren,
starren Regeln aufstellen können.
Also, es kommen halt oft Leute rein,
beleidigend, die aber 'n Punkt haben.
Kann auch 'n Quatschpunkt sein,
aber den sie ernsthaft finden
und über den andere
vielleicht auch ernsthaft nachdenken.
Zum Beispiel hier,
(Piepser) hat gesagt:
"Adenovirus erzeugt Krebs."
Da ist ja kein Getrolle.
Das ist jemand,
der das wirklich glaubt. - Ja.
Und da wär sinnvoll,
wenn jemand Zeit und Muße hat,
drunter zu schreiben,
warum das nicht so ist.
Und das machen auch viele.
Aber dieses Bedürfnis,
den jetzt zurückzubeleidigen,
weil der mich nervt,
das ist halt Unsinn.
Es gibt aber auch Leute,
die wollen dich beleidigen.
Also die richtigen Trolle.
Und das sind die,
über die wir grade reden,
die uns die Kommentarspalte
kaputtmachen,
glaub ich, hauptsächlich.
Und die gucken dann, wo sie
den Finger in die Wunde kriegen,
und machen genau da weiter.
"Uhh, du findest das gemein,
in China hätte man das
wohl nicht gemacht, wie?"
Die machen halt genau so weiter.
Da muss man sich halt bewusst sein,
dass das auch passiert.
Davon abgesehen
wollen wir uns mit Löschen
und Blocken möglichst zurückhalten,
denn es gibt auch noch
zwei weitere Arten und Weisen,
mit unschönen Kommentaren umzugehen.
Und vor allem die letzte
ist so powerful
und gleichzeitig
so unterschätzt.
Aber erst mal zweitens:
Bei uns werden natürlich
viele Falschinformationen
in die Kommentare gepostet.
Zum Beispiel, dass mRNA-Impfstoffe
das Erbgut verändern.
Wenn das wie gesagt
in Spamform passiert,
wird das ja eh gelöscht,
aber grundsätzlich
ist es unser Selbstverständnis,
dass wir Falschinformationen
nicht einfach löschen,
sondern dass wir ihnen
mit Fakten begegnen
und sie richtigstellen.
Außerdem, wenn wir jetzt
hier in unserer Kommentarspalte
Falschinformationen löschen, tauchen
sie ja trotzdem anderswo noch auf.
Oft kommen sie ja sogar
von anderen YouTube-Videos,
wo solche Falschinformationen
entweder bewusst verbreitet werden
oder wo Leute auch vielleicht
einfach mal was missverstanden haben.
Und da ist es ja viel konstruktiver,
hier bei unserem Kanal,
der ja in der Regel
die größere Reichweite hat,
und wo auch mehr Leute einfach still
mitlesen in der Kommentarspalte,
dass wir hier Aufklärung betreiben
und Falsches gegebenenfalls
dann auch debunken.
Unsere Kapazitäten sind da
wie gesagt leider begrenzt.
Aber viele Freunde der Sonne
sind offensichtlich so gut darin,
Falschinformationen mit Fakten und
schlüssigen Argumenten zu begegnen,
es ist wirklich ...
Es ist so nice.
Und so was dann zu lesen,
das berührt uns regelrecht. Wirklich.
Weil das ja genau das ist,
was wir hier möchten.
Wir wollen aufklären,
aber wir wollen auch
euch dazu ermutigen aufzuklären.
Also ein Aufklärungs-
Superspreading-Event sein.
Und es macht uns so glücklich,
dann so was zu sehen
und zu sehen,
dass es funktioniert.
Was sehr oft passiert leider,
ist, dass man
an den Kommentaren sieht,
dass das Video nicht
oder nicht aufmerksam geschaut wurde.
Zum Beispiel, dass da
Falschinformationen auftauchen,
die im Video selbst
aber schon debunked wurden,
oder dass man schreibt,
warum verschweigt sie dies und das,
obwohl es im Video sehr wohl
behandelt wurde.
Und da könnt ihr,
die ihr das Video gesehen habt,
uns natürlich auch super helfen.
Entweder, indem ihr es
selber noch mal erklärt,
indem ihr zum Beispiel
einen Timecode postet
zu der Stelle im Video
wo's erklärt wird,
oder meinetwegen auch, indem ihr sehr
sachlich, freundlich darauf hinweist
oder empfehlt,
das Video sich doch mal anzuschauen.
Ich fänd's schön und wichtig,
wenn wir in dieser Community
uns im Ton nicht
runterziehen lassen von anderen,
sondern dass wir
immer respektvoll bleiben
und sachlich bleiben.
Ich hab noch ein Beispiel:
Ist nicht sehr beleidigend,
aber ist so,
wo man sofort als jemand,
der an dem Skript beteiligt war,
denkt: "Ja, du Affe!"
"Erstens hast du's falsch,
und dann kommst du hier noch
so arrogant-beschissen rüber."
So will man ja reagieren.
Hat der geantwortet:
"Danke."
Und das find ich ziemlich cool.
Nur wenn man selbst
sachlich und respektvoll bleibt,
egal, was vom andern vorher kam,
gibt es überhaupt ne Chance,
dass diese, ja, Aufklärungsarbeit,
die ihr da grade macht,
überhaupt auch ankommt.
Überhaupt ist Sachlichkeit
ganz oft nur ne Frage des Tons.
Und Moderieren ist da
erstaunlich oft erfolgreich.
Ich mach jetzt
seit sechs Jahren YouTube.
Meine Erfahrung ist,
dass viele böse Kommentare
aus der Erwartung heraus
geschrieben werden,
dass sie eh niemand liest.
Und wenn man dann doch mal
drauf eingeht und antwortet,
und sachlich und respektvoll bleibt,
hab ich's schon so oft erlebt,
dass sich der Ton
komplett ändert.
Dass sich Leute sogar
entschuldigen dafür und dann sagen:
Sorry, ich hatte 'n schlechten Tag.
Und genau so was könnt ihr,
als Community, natürlich auch.
Wenn wir uns hier
einen sachlicheren Ton wünschen,
dann müssen wir,
die vernünftige Mehrheit,
diesen Ton vorgeben.
Wenn auf so was
dann aber nicht reagiert wird,
wenn dieser Versachlichungsversuch
nicht ankommt,
dann würde ich
keine Sekunde länger mehr
mit dieser Person verschwenden.
Denn jetzt kommen wir zu drittens:
Was soll man dazu sagen?
Ich brauch das nicht zu löschen,
ich finde,
das lässt nicht mich dumm dastehen,
sondern die Person,
die so was schreibt.
Drauf zu reagieren
brauch ich sowieso nicht.
Ignorieren
ist das einzig Sinnvolle hier.
Und ich kann euch nicht genug
dazu ermutigen:
Ignoriert solche Sachen einfach auch.
Habt auch bitte nie das Gefühl,
mich oder uns
verteidigen zu müssen.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Es gibt sogar Falschinformationen,
wo wir sagen:
Das ist überhaupt nicht wert
oder nicht nötig, debunked zu werden.
Solche Kommentare
diskreditieren sich selbst
durch ihre eigene Bananigkeit.
Da braucht man nix zu antworten,
das ... Was? Warum? Warum?
Dann fängste an,
mit irgendwelchen Besoffenen im
Internet hin und her zu schreien,
das würdest du schon auf der Straße
nicht machen.
Du willst ja nicht
ne halbe Stunde stehenbleiben,
um dich
mit irgendsonem Asi zu streiten,
sondern du wirst halt weitergehen.
Im Internet auch.
Was wir auch ignorieren,
sind sogenannte
"Strohmann"-Serientäter.
Man sollte manche Provokation im Netz
einfach ignorieren,
weil sowieso keine konstruktive
Diskussion möglich ist.
Ach so,
mit dir sollen alle diskutieren,
aber was dir nicht gefällt, das
würdest du am liebsten ausschalten.
Nein,
ich will nur nicht drauf reagieren,
und ich empfehle das anderen,
auch nicht zu tun.
Du möchtest mal wieder
allen die Meinung vorgeben.
Ich sag doch nur,
dass man Dinge, die man doof findet,
nicht mit seiner Aufmerksamkeit
belohnen sollte.
Wenn jemand vor deinen Augen auf der
Straße niedergeschlagen wird ...
Das geht jetzt ewig so weiter.
Gleichzeitig sind diese Kommentare,
bei denen wir Ignorieren empfehlen,
natürlich super provozierend.
"It's a trap!"
Widersteht dem Impuls!
Ich weiß, ihr habt ne superwitzige,
schlagfertige Antwort,
die kitzelt euch schon
in den Fingern.
Aber lasst es.
Auf sämtlichen Internetplattformen,
die durch Werbung finanziert werden,
wie YouTube auch, ist Aufmerksamkeit
buchstäblich gleich Geld.
Und selbst unsere Videos, unsere
öffentlich-rechtlichen Funk-Videos,
wo wir keine Werbung schalten,
unterliegen ja trotzdem dem gleichen,
werbegetriebenen Algorithmus.
Und für den Algorithmus
ist jede Art von Aufmerksamkeit,
jedes Engagement, jeder Daumen hoch,
aber auch jeder Daumen runter,
jeder Kommentar,
sei er gut oder böse,
gleich Sichtbarkeit.
Schließlich will jede Plattform,
dass ihr hier
so viel Zeit wie möglich verbringt.
Das heißt, jeder Inhalt, sei es
'n Video oder auch 'n Kommentar,
mit dem ihr engaged,
mit dem ihr euch aufhaltet,
ist für den Algorithmus gut und
wird mit mehr Sichtbarkeit belohnt.
Unabhängig davon, ob ihr
diesen Inhalt gut oder blöd findet.
Wir vermuten zum Beispiel auch,
dass Dislike-Angriffe
auf unsere Videos,
zu denen tatsächlich
regelmäßig aufgerufen wird
von diversen
Wissenschaftsverweigerern,
dass die dazu beitragen,
dass unsere Videos
überhaupt erst in den Trends landen
oder schneller dahin kommen
oder länger darin verweilen.
Wir würden natürlich lieber
auf diesen Push verzichten,
denn genau deswegen
bekommen wir ja solche Nachrichten.
Aber das Video selbst wird dadurch
natürlich schon mehr gesehen.
Erst mal die Aufrufe
durch die Leute,
die hier hinkommen
um das Video zu disliken,
und gegebenenfalls
auch ein algorithmischer Push,
der dadurch erst entsteht.
Etwas, das man doof findet,
Aufmerksamkeit zu geben,
geht eigentlich immer
nach hinten los.
Ihr könnt in unseren Kommentaren
natürlich nichts blocken,
das können nur wir,
das ist unser Kanal.
Aber ich sag euch nur:
Ignorieren ist genauso effizient
wie blocken.
Denn ein Kommentar,
mit dem niemand engaged,
den dann niemand liest,
oder eine Provokation,
auf die niemand eingeht ...
hat auch keinen Impact.
Ausgerechnet diejenigen,
die was von unterdrückter
Meinungsfreiheit,
von Demokratiegefährdung
und von Diktatur querfaseln,
haben auch diejenigen
in ihren Reihen,
die dann Journalisten angreifen
oder Wissenschaftlerinnen
Morddrohungen schicken.
Das ist alles sehr frustrierend.
Aber es ist auch wirklich
weniger schlimm als es erscheint.
Denn es handelt sich hier
um eine sehr kleine Minderheit,
die aber einfach nur
sehr laut pöbelt,
und dafür sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit -
da haben wir's wieder - bekommt.
Hinzu kommt:
Der Hate hat ja
auch deswegen zugenommen,
weil meine Reichweite auch
stark gewachsen ist.
Das heißt,
diese besagte Minderheit
nimmt mich und meine Arbeit
als Bedrohung war,
weil ich ja tatsächlich viel Einfluss
mit dieser großen Reichweite habe.
Das heißt, der Hate
ist proportional zur Reichweite.
Und deswegen konzentriere ich mich
ziemlich unbeirrt auf Letzteres,
auf meine Plattform,
auf meine Inhalte,
mit denen ich
sehr viele Menschen erreichen darf,
deren Meinungen nicht repräsentativ
in den Kommentaren auftauchen,
weil die meisten
nun einmal still zuschauen.
Okay, aber wer ist denn
diese "Reichweite"?
Das seid ihr.
Ihr seid es,
warum das hier jetzt
ein einflussreicher Kanal ist.
Eure Aufmerksamkeit,
die Aufmerksamkeit
eines jeden einzelnen von euch,
entscheidet über den Erfolg
von Inhalten.
Wie gesagt, es gibt natürlich Dinge,
die wir nicht tolerieren sollten.
Aber davon abgesehen,
jetzt mal wirklich:
Lassen wir uns nicht viel zu oft
von Dingen provozieren,
die unsere Aufmerksamkeit
überhaupt nicht verdient haben?
Außerdem, wisst ihr,
ich erzähl euch hier was
von unserer begrenzten Kapazität
und red hier nur
von unserer Arbeitszeit.
Bei euch ist es ja
auch noch eure Freizeit!
Das ist eure Lebenszeit!
Channelt euren inneren Drosten.
Ihr habt Besseres zu tun.
Vielleicht bin ich ja auch naiv.
Aber ich hoffe einfach,
dass jeder Einzelne von euch
uns hier im Team helfen kann,
für alle ein besseres
Diskussionsklima hier zu schaffen.
Und vielleicht bin ich
auch deswegen naiv,
weil ihr uns jetzt schon
seit viereinhalb Jahren
immer wieder zeigt, was für eine
geile Community ihr seid.
Ihr habt uns durch eure Kommentare
schon so viel Motivation,
Mut und Freude gemacht.
Und immer
wenn die Kommentarspalte
mal wieder aussieht
wie 'n Schlachtfeld,
konzentrieren wir uns auf Kommentare
wie diese hier,
und schöpfen daraus
immer wieder neuen Antrieb.
Und dafür wollen wir euch
ein ganz fettes DANKE sagen.
Keksempfehlung geht heute raus
an unsere Funk-Kolleginnen
von "So Many Tabs",
Kanal rund um Internet, IT, zum
Beispiel dieser Messengervergleich:
Was ist ne gute Alternative
zu Whatsapp?
Kann Telegram mehr als nur
Verschwörungsmythen inkubieren?
Schaut da gerne mal vorbei.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns bald,
bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.